in this video I'm bringing your theory
image on engineers targaryen will marry
in the final season of Game of Thrones
this theory is backed up with quite a
few clues and foreshadows from both the
TV show and the book series so it out
further ado let's just jump into it the
marriage of Ice and Fire was expected
already take place in the previous
season of Game of Thrones considering
that the potential solar investor else
was the main reason Daenerys left her
lover Darian Hart's behind in Mereen in
the season six finale
however Game of Thrones Season seven did
see Ice and Fire come together as Jon
Snow in the near Targaryen finally met
and promptly fell in love since then he
did not come to Westeros only concrete
but also to build a stable order and
reunite all those Seven Kingdoms of
which monster in open rebellion against
the crown Jon Snow was and still is the
only logical suitor for Dany
not only that jon is the only logical
option since as a king jon is one of the
most powerful people in some kingdoms
one of a few men who actually has any
authority and respect from his people
that who fight beside him to the bitter
end but their pairing would also fulfill
ancient pact between those two houses a
pact that is dating all the way back
before Eris is madness
all the way back to the Civil War
between the Targaryen known as the dance
of the Dragons war image how Starks
support the claim of a queen rhaenyra
targaryen a pact that was sustained with
the condition in which a Targaryen a
real princess would marry a stark
disagreement known as the pact of Ice
and Fire was never fulfilled but it
could change in the final season since
the nares doesn't want only to conquer
the Seven Kingdoms but wants to make it
a better place wants to build a stable
structure and marrying Johnston will
bring her support and control over the
kingdom that is large as the other six
combined as proven in the season 7
finale even though the army of the Dead
is marching to kill the entire looming
side proving alliances to people is
still of the great importance in that
episode in the chamber of the painting
table Daenerys and her court discuss
logistics John says it'll take the track
here fortnight to reach Winterfell while
they can sail with the unsullied to
white Harbor and window tracking on the
kingsroad
this is Ventura proposes the nearest red
or fly to Winterfell as he points out
that the north is not really safe for
her she has many enemies there and all
it takes is one angry man with a
crossbow and an idea becoming a hero by
killing the Targaryen conquer with one
well-placed bow
Jon then states that it's her decision
but if they are going to be allies in
this for it's important for the
northerners to see them as one John
basically convinces the nearest that if
they are to sail together it sends a
better message since the north will see
her as an ally rather than conqueror if
sailing together sends a better message
than wearing would most certainly seal
their alliance
additionally John and Danny have already
began an intimate relationship although
neither one of them is currently aware
of their family ties as well remember in
the season 7 finale we saw the to hook
up well brands voiceover was explaining
that they are in fact related
since John and Danny are headed to
Winterfell it is likely that bran and
Sam will reveal the truth about John's
shoe heritage early on in the season
clearly this revelation of dinners being
John's aunt will come as a huge shock to
both of them and who most certainly
changed their relationship even though
it's a Shias pairings have never bought
her Targaryen since I might even say
that it will not bother Jon in the near
cedar as their Targaryen themselves
you're completely wrong
Targaryen did spend over 300 years
reading brother to sister in order to
keep their bloodline pure true
Daenerys parents heirs met King and red
lever siblings and Daenerys did grow up
believing she would marry her brother
Viserys also true but as simply is not
the same even though intermarriage is
accepted Industrials
and expected for Targaryen John was not
raised as a Targaryen and likely will
not embrace their family traditions as
proa numerous times jasmine is as
honorable as Ned Stark and in this case
his honor and very stoic sense of right
and wrong will most likely prevent him
from continuing a relationship with his
aunt throughout the series it has been
established that first-degree incest
outside of the Targaryen family such as
Craster and his daughters and of course
the most popular incest couple Jaime and
Cersei is considered wrong and immoral
intermarriage between first cousins on
the other hand is not considered incest
in Westeros a society the prominent
example is the time Lannister murdered
his own cousin Joanna Lannister mother
of all three of his children however
John and Danny are not cousins nor are
they siblings their nephew and aunt and
therefore many are wondering if they
bill upon finding out the truth still
marry each other to seal their alliance
the answer on that question is both yes
and no yes there will be the Targaryen
marriage in the fifth episode of the
final season but no they will not marry
out of love nor because they want to
seal their alliance they will do it
because of their child I know you might
be a bit confused so let's get a little
bit back no Jan and Daenerys will not
continue their intimate relationship
after they find out the truth ritual by
the way takes place in the very
beginning of the final season but they
don't have to because the nurse already
got pregnant in the season 7 finale it's
been highlighted numerous times during
this season that there
believes she can no longer have children
because of a prophecy that was told to
her by me rhemas during the season 1
finale the prophecy tells when the Sun
rises in the West and sets in the east
when the Seas go dry and the mountains
blow in the wind like leaves and your
own quickens again and your bearer
living child then he will return and not
before
despite the nurses believe that she
cannot have children because of this
prophecy then it will most definitely be
pregnant with John's baby next time we
see her the show's next big dress was
heavily foreshadowed her the previous
season for an example it was
foreshadowed by John questioning the
nurses assertion of infertility
particularly men she admits that she
never got an informed opinion about her
condition from anyone except Mary
mazdoor herself as well remember in the
season 7 finale the nurse will to join
her belief of not being able to bear
children I can't have children the nurse
said who told you that John asked the
witch come murdered my husband the nurse
replied in case you don't remember me
Remus d'Or was the witch who killed a
nurse his unborn child and put Khal
Drogo in a vegetative state
Mira mazdoor wanted to push the nearest
century ago for killing her people the
nurse asked me mazdoor when Drogo would
be as once he was again when the Sun
rises in the West and sets in the east
door sat on show when the Seas go dry
and the mountains blow in the wind like
leaves however the show excluded a
significant portion of the witch's
prophecy in the books she also said when
your room quickens again and you
barrelling child then he will return and
not before that is the reason the
nearest believed she cannot bear
children anyways and then your will herb
leave to John he basically called her
out on this assumption as it occurred to
you she might not have been a reliable
source information John says of door
just a jump pointed out the witch who
killed her husband and curse her is not
a reliable source of information as to
her current health
additionally John Stone becoming a
fighter was foreshadowed a few times as
well with the most prominent one being
Jorah talking to John about John's
future child when John offered to give
Longclaw back to house moment Jorah
fused as he brought shame on his family
and therefore he has no longer the right
to wield weapon more importantly Jorah
stated that the sword must remain with
John as his father wanted and it has to
pass to John's son once John dies not to
him nor anyone from house moment when he
insists that John keeps sword he
basically gifted Longclaw with these
words may it serve you well and your
children after you long story short Dany
definitely is going to bear a child many
times the show talks about Dennis
infertile State then his dragon says
being her only children the succession
line issue
John passing Longclaw to his offspring
if then he could never bear children
again the show would not return to this
issue instead it keeps returning to this
topic in the same way it keeps returning
to John status as a bastard so then he's
most likely getting pregnant we're all
expecting the Targaryen marriage but
having in mind that John will most
certainly find out about his true
parentage almost at the same time the
nurse tells him that they're about to
have a baby
quite amount offense also doubt that
this marriage will actually take place
well here's a huge surprise for you this
marriage is actually happening a bit
later in the season I know you are still
wondering how does Daenerys being
pregnant change the fact that they are
related which of course it doesn't and
therefore why would they marry but give
me a few moments to explain it to you
even though both of them will without a
doubt refused to even think about the
marriage whether it's political or out
of love in the beginning of the season
upon learning that there are nephew and
aunt they'll have him strong reasons to
do so later in the season and that
reason is going to be the near vs.
pregnancy once they learn of their
family ties the other news will hit them
the already mentioned Annie's pregnancy
with John's baby and that exact news
will make them change their mind and
actually marry each other and here's why
jack has been a bastard son his entire
life and he most certainly will not
allow his child to be born out of
wedlock and live a life he has been
living both in the books and on the show
John initially refuses to sleep with
women because he is absolutely terrified
that he might produce a bastard in the
fourth episode of the very first season
there was a small talk between John and
Sam on Sam's assumption that John had
been with hundreds of girls so far John
answered with no as a matter of fact the
same as you John then goes on to
describe his only chance with a girl he
says so I said there in the brothel as
ROS took off her clothes but I couldn't
do it because all I could think was what
if I got her pregnant and she had a
child another bastard named snow it's
not a good life for a child knowing how
hard it is to grow up like that he had
no problem with joining the Nights Watch
and never fathering a child even when he
falls in love with a grid it's hard for
him to get over this fear of intimacy
that might lead to pregnancy as I've
already said just like on the show John
doesn't want to father a child in the
book theater while having a conversation
with his uncle Benjen about the Nights
Watch John said I will never father a
bastard never the fact that John himself
is not actually a bastard but
illegitimate son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna stark and true heir to the
Iron Throne is highly ironic of course
but it doesn't change the way he grew up
and it most definitely will not change
his desire not
bring another bastard named snow into
the world in conclusion the final season
will see the targaryen marriage once the
nurse reveals her pregnancy to John and
the only reason being their child if
this theory comes sure what color do you
think would label this wedding don't
forget that we've already had red and
purple wedding